Alright,
so now we have something interesting and
unexpected.
Close this off with the floor is yours,
Dr Peterson.
I'd like to say thank you for making
your videos available online.
They had a great effect on me over the
last year.
Actually found them a few years ago,
but sometime around July or August of
last year,
I got hooked.
I would wake up at like 5:00
AM in the morning to watch your maps of
meaning releases the new ones,
the old ones,
etc.
Etc.
Um,
I found mysElf inspired by both the
academic and technicals a material as
well as what I might term the more
fatherly directives or wisdom.
I shared this with my family and my
friends as well as my girlfriend.
She's here tonight as well.
She's been following the biblical
series.
Well,
what I'd like to say is thank yoU for
inspiring me to stand up and face
something that I've been afraid of all
my adult life.
And thank you for granting me the
permission to ask this question here.
It's actually for my girlfriend.
Will you please stand up?
So some might say,
gIven that we are a couple of primates
full of snakes,
it's pretty miraculous that we haven't
killed each other,
but
I think you're pretty great.
We've been talking about commitment and
I think I'm ready now.
I'm ready to commit to a life with you
of sorting ourselves out.
I'd like to clean some rooms with you.
And even as scary as the shackles of
marriage have been made to seem to us,
um,
I'm thinking about forever and simply in
my,
in my words,
I love you dearly.
You feel like home.
I never want to lose the will.
You marry me.
And if you want to come here,
thank you.
So you're seeing,
you're going to shackle yourself to me.
I'd never run away then I shall suffer
the rest of my life with you.